All right,
so today I want to do something a little bit more mundane than we did on Monday.
I wanted to go back and talk about quantity competition.
So in the,
in the first half of the course,
we talked about price competition.
We talked about quantity,
competition,
we talked about competition with differentiated products.
I want to go back and revisit essentially the core no model.
So this was the core no model.
The two firms are producing a,
choosing their quantities simultaneously from one is choosing Q1 and from two is
choosing Q2.
And we had all of this is just reviews and this is all stuff that's in your
notes and ready.
This is the demand curve.
It tells us that prices depend on the total quantity being produced.
So this is Q one plus Q two and this is prices than the demand curve is a
straight line of Slope B.
All right?
That's what that,
that's what this tells us.
Is that a slope mine,
that's me.
All right.
And we know that payoffs are just profits,
which are price times quantity,
revenues minus cost,
time,
quantity costs or get swimming,
constant marginal costs.
And we did this model out in full in maybe the third week of class and we
figured out what the best response diagram looked like.
And if you remember correctly,
this was the best response from one taking from two his output as given,
and this is the best response
for from to taking from one output has given.
And there were a few other details in here.
This was the monopoly quantity.
This was competitive quantity and so on.
But this is,
this is enough for today.
And actually we'd done a bit more than that.
We'd actually worked out in class what the equations were for these best
responses.
Here they are,
and I'm,
I'm not going to read,
arrive these today,
but there's somewhere in your notes.
We kind of crunch through some calculus and figured out what foam ones best
response looks like al directly.
Here it is.
So this is the equation of this line and similarly for from too.
So this is the equation of this one.
All right.
And finally we figured out what the Nash Equilibrium was and there was no prizes
here.
The Nash Equilibrium in Corno was where these best response is crossed and this
is the equation for the battle for that for now,
she could have them.
Have you made a mistake?
Uh,
the best.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you.
Best respond to best.
Responsible for from one is a function of Q two exactly.
Thanks Jake.
All right,
so this is all stuff we did before.
I want to go back to this model now to revisit it in the context of thinking
about sequential dynamic games.
So we're going to do is we're going to imagine that rather than having these
firms choose their quantities simultaneously,
one firm gets to move first.
And the other from moves after.
Let's be clear what we're going to assume that one firm is moving first and the
other firm for what was it was assume from one's going to move first.
The other firm to from to is going to get to observe what foam one is chosen and
then get to make a choice.
All right.
So we're just gonna see how,
what difference it makes when we go from this classic simultaneous move came
into a sequential move game.
Alright?
And this model is fairly famous and I almost got the spelling this wrong,
but it's due to a guy called Stackelberg.
So what we're looking at now is the Stackelberg mark.
Alright.
So how do you want to think about this?
So not a,
a natural question to have bear in mind is assuming where this world of quantity
competition,
is it an advantage to get to move first?
Does tech one's quantity first or is this an advantage to be able to wait,
see what the other firm has done and then respond,
right?
Is there an advantage in going first or as an advantage in knowing a bit more
about what,
uh,
about the other firm and being able to move second?
All right,
that's to me the question at the back of our mind for most of today.
so how are we going to,
how are we going to think of this?
How are we going to figure this out?
It shouldn't be,
it shouldn't be a silence in the room.
There should be an instant answer.
How are we going to figure this out?
We're going to use backward induction,
right?
This is gonna be an exercise in backward induction.
We won't be able to draw a tree here because the games too complicated because
there's a consumer of actions,
but nevertheless,
we are going to use backward induction.
So what does using backward induction,
Meagan here using backward induction means starting at the end and the end is
what?
The end here is from two right from one is going to move first from just going
to observe that choice and then move.
So the end of the game is from too.
So we're going to solve that from two's problem first.
And we're actually going to do this entire analysis twice.
We're first of all going to do this analysis a bit intuitively looking at
pictures and then they want to go back and crunch and out in the math.
All right.
You want to,
you used to seeing that we can actually do it.
Crunch Lee.
All right,
so this but this,
but this board is just review,
so I'm going to get rid of it.
I think
I didn't manage to get rid of it.
I have mine.
We're not going to be using this board.
This is just what we did do and the same in the simultaneous move game.
So we'll get rid of it.
All right,
so in the sequential move game,
we're going to start by analyzing the mover from two.
All right?
So imagine yourself as a manager of from to you're coming along to meet your
output decision,
right?
The output or from one is already set.
All right.
Analyze from two first
from two C's.
Q1 Hi anonymous.
Choose huge too.
So what is from to going to do?
What's fun to
going to do?
So I claim we already know this.
We've already solved this problem.
When do we solve this problem?
And they want to no know when we solve this problem,
the problem of what from who's going to do,
oh,
we already solved it.
But a month ago when we looked at the sort of the same old tennis moved game
because what we worked out then was what is from tos best response for any
particular choice that foam one makes.
All right.
We already sold out that problem.
It was kind of a,
it took us a while to sell out,
but basically it was the Max maximize from two's pay off taking has given from
one.
We already know what the equation looks like and it's just remind ourselves what
the picture looked like.
Just a repeat of the picture you had before.
We said for any particular choice of from one from two's best response can be
drawn on a best response diagram.
Okay,
and it looks like this.
It's exactly the picture we have up there.
All right,
so this is the best response for from to taking us given the choice of from one.
Okay.
All right.
And we even know the equation of it.
I went well the rewrite it,
that ordinary equation.
All right,
so in some sense from two's problem is a problem.
We've already seen it.
We already worked out in months ago.
What from two should do it,
uh,
taking a foam ones output has given and that's exactly the problem from two
fines herself.
And she wakes up one morning,
[inaudible] has been said already and now she must choose Q Q Q two to maximize
their profits.
So there's going to choose her best response.
And just to remind you how we read this picture for any particular choice of Q1,
we'd go up to the line and look across,
this tells us what Q2 will respond.
All right?
Two of Q one chooses this amount.
Then Q2 while she was this amount,
if Q1 chooses this amount and Q two we'll choose this amount and so on.
All right,
so there's no mystery here.
We already know what from two is going to do.
All right?
So by definition,
my definition,
the best response of two to Q1,
how's us
the
profit maximizing?
Oh,
push.
Awesome too.
Taking Q1
I was given.
All right,
so we've done the second,
we'd done the second step,
but this is already,
we already know what from two's going to do.
Of course the additional step here now is it from one knows that foam two's
going to do this for one is going to move first and from one knows that after
she sets how quantity Q1 from two will respond by choosing how corresponding
corresponding quantity,
which is the best response to it.
So from one news that affirmed one where the shoes,
this quantity then from two will respond by choosing this quantity and from one
knows that if he,
if she chose this,
the smaller quantity and from to all respond by choosing this larger quantity,
is that right?
Is that right?
So from one can anticipate how from two is going to respond to each of these
choices.
All right,
so let's just make that clear.
So in particular if from one was to choose Q one hat,
I'm not suggesting it should,
but if from one was to choose this Q one hats than he knows,
then phone one knows that from to we'll produce this quantity,
which is the best response to Q one hat.
And if I'm one would choose Q one double hat and firms who will respond by
choosing the best response to Q one double hat.
All right,
so this is pretty straight forward so far,
but what we are able to see now is the problem of facing from one which is the
interesting problem.
The problem facing from one is what quantity should from one shoes.
Knowing that this is how from two is going to respond and before we saw this out
mathematically,
I just want to think it through a little bit.
So the first way I want to think this through is it's it made the following
observation from phone one's point of view from one knows that any Q1 she
chooses leads to a response on this line by from too.
That's what phone one knows.
So from one is effectively choosing points on this line for one is effectively
choosing points on this line.
Let me say it again.
It's what what's actually happening is from one is choosing Q1 and from two is
responding by choosing a Kutu that puts them on this mind.
But in effect,
that means from one is choosing points on this line.
All right?
So you can think of from one's problem as choose the joint output level on this
line that maximizes from ones profits that we could think of.
Pheromones,
problem as choose the combination of outputs on this line by choosing Q one and
Q two respond,
choose the combination on this line that maximizes profits for from one try.
Unbelievable.
And there's a little bit because it,
it's,
it's a more general mathematical idea here.
How many of you are in Econ one 50 right now?
Right?
So for those of you an econ one 50 this is should be a very familiar kind of
thing.
That is a constrained optimization problem and you've been having constrained
optimization problems rammed into for the last month or so.
Right?
So this is an example of a constrained optimization,
right?
You have to choose a point,
but you can't use a point freely.
You have to choose a point on the line.
All right.
Okay,
so let's talk about it a bit more before we do the math.
All right.
That's actually redraw it again,
since I made a mess of this picture.
So one thing you might want to ask is in making this choice for from one should
from one shoes more or less or the same as it used to choose when the problem
was simultaneous.
All right,
so let's put in again what it used to choose when the problem was simultaneous.
I'll put it in just faintly.
Okay,
so here's our old corn.
Oh,
pitcher up like this.
All right.
And this was the quantity,
but from one show is in the core no game.
So let me call that Q one c.
Okay.
All right.
So certainly one possibility is that from one could choose her core,
no quantity,
right?
You can certainly do that.
And she knows that if she does that from two will respond by choosing the best
response of I'm too to from one choosing the corner quantity.
But we know what that is.
What's what's from two's best response to foam ones,
quantity,
it's foam two's,
corner quantity,
right?
So if I'm,
if I'm too does that,
if someone chooses,
if I'm one chooses the corner quantity then from to what also choose the corner
quantity.
So one thing that from one could do as effectively choose the old equilibrium.
All right,
that's it.
And something that's something that that's available to from one,
but someone could also do other things from one could produce less than that or
from one could do more than that.
All right,
so who thinks from one should play?
It should choose the old equilibrium quantity.
Who thinks Fev one to choose more than that?
He thinks from launch,
which was less than that.
He went to a majority of this.
Just try it with a camera on you.
All right.
All right,
so once again,
how am I,
how many people think that the phone,
why you should choose the old equilibrium quantity,
dribbling of hands.
And how about less than that?
You hadn't and they went down again.
Then how about more than that?
There's a majority of a more turns out.
More as correct.
That's good.
That's good news.
It's good news.
Why?
Why do we think from one should produce more than it used to produce before?
Let they take us on this.
What does thinking about it as from one produces more or if from one month to
produce more.
Then from to that my voice is going then from two would produce what lasts.
All right?
As from one produces more than her corner quantity from two's response is to
produce less.
All right.
Does anyone remember the jargon for this?
What?
What do we call games where the more I do have my strategy,
the less you do have yours.
Strategic substitutes.
Good.
This is a game of strategic substitutes.
It's game of strategic substitutes and what that means is that as Q one goes
out,
Kutu the best response affirm to the Q one goes down.
So Watch.
So what?
We got that,
that's good.
I just want to get the picture.
Well,
the,
so wars is now we're in,
now we're in a sequential game.
It film one produces more than her corner quantity.
She induces from two to produce less as we just said.
And that's what that's good for from one,
right?
My producing more inducing youtube produce last is good for me.
It's going to keep prices higher and the market is that right?
So let's just think it through again in the core,
no equilibrium.
The choice of from one was the best choice for from one taking.
The choice of two is given,
but that was the quite old court over quantity,
right?
But now we're in the Stackelberg setting.
It's a sequential setting.
There's an additional feature from one doesn't have to take from two's output
has given.
There's an additional reason for producing all right?
At the margin,
which is at the margin.
If I produced the more units of output that leads you to produce last,
which is good for me.
All right?
So that suggests that I'm going to produce more than I used to produce under the
old assumption.
All right,
so this suggests,
I suggest that
a fun one
should set,
he won bigger than Q one c to induce
Q two to be less than QTC.
Alright.
So the first thing we've learned,
we'll see this in the math later,
is that from one will in fact produce more than they used to under core know and
that will result in from to producing last one.
Now,
all right,
now we're already got a lot on the board.
Now that we can actually solve that intuitively the problem,
do we think that from one's profits by this procedure are the same as they were
under Kono?
Are they less than they were under corno or are they more than they were under
Cornell?
Because,
let me say again from one is going first.
Now we've argued that from one's going to produce more.
Do we think the foam ones,
profits and the end of the day are going to be the same as they were under corno
higher than than they were under corno although than they were in the corner.
So let's have a poll again and we get ready to get the get the camera on you
guys.
So who thinks that profits are going to be the same as they were under corner?
We thinks the province is going to go.
I've gone up.
I think the profit's gone down now.
We're in good shape.
Pay Cause indeed the profits have gone up.
It's a very simple argument where the profits after we've gone up,
why do,
how do we know the profits must have gone up?
Let me actually,
is this simple?
Nothing to grab a Mike on this.
How do we know the profits just must've got up there was a hand or the back.
It was a hand in the back.
Yes.
Okay.
Way at the back.
How do we know profits must have gone up here way at the back.
Yeah.
If from I was going to lower their province,
they wouldn't have chosen to produce more.
All right,
good.
Exactly.
The fact that from one has changed,
the output in a particular producing more tells you they must be able to to
increase their profits by this,
by this maneuver,
right.
There's this thing,
it's so think that through.
One option that was available to from one before was to set out on the core no
level.
If I'm one had set output at the corner level,
that would have laid the firm to just set output at the corner level and on an I
in that case,
profits would have been exactly the same as before.
The fight from one has moved away from that must mean they're a higher profit
available.
Said another way from one could have had exactly what it had before too.
It must do,
it must be doing at least as well as it was doing before and the fact it's
changed,
music must be doing better than it was doing before.
All right,
so indeed from one's profits have gone up.
Oh,
I'm on,
profits have gone up.
We don't even need any math to prove that.
It must,
it just must be the case.
Uh,
logically.
All right.
What must have happened to from two's profits?
What are things happening to foam tubes,
profits.
So that's not,
that's also immediately obvious,
right?
It's all various.
I think the foam ones,
profits have gone up yet because foam one could have had the same old profits
and as chosen something else,
but it's not immediately obvious what happened to from two's.
Profits does that right now,
before we get to what's happened to from to profits,
let's go through an intermediate step.
Let's try and ask what must have happened to total outputs in the market in this
example.
And it's nice,
simple example,
right?
We did that.
That's not immediately obvious either.
Why we've argued that from one's output went up,
but from two outputs when down roles you have to core no,
right?
So it's not immediately obvious whether the sum of those two Q one plus Q two
went up or down,
right?
We'd like to know what happens to Q one plus Q two total output on the market.
And by the way,
I,
one particular reason we might care about this is of course consumers would like
it to have gone up.
If total output,
it's gone up,
price has gone down and that's good for consumers,
right?
So if you're the regulator,
if you're just,
if you're designing this industry,
if you're working for the Justice Department,
if you're working for the European Commission,
you're going to want to know the answer.
When we switched from a simultaneous simultaneous testing to an asymmetric
setting,
where there's a leader from and a follower from is not going to be good for
consumers or bad for consumers.
All right,
well let's have a look.
Well,
we know that foam ones output up and we know that from two's output went down,
but can anyone tell me what happened to total output and why?
There's a poll again.
Who thinks total outputs?
Who thinks total output went down?
Okay.
Who thinks total outputs stayed the same?
Yeah,
I think it's total output went up.
There's lots of extensions.
Let's try that again.
Cause too many extensions.
Who thinks total output,
right?
Who thinks total output went down?
I think it's total output will stay the same.
Who thinks total output went up?
That's pretty split,
so I think total out,
I know actually the total output went up and I claim I can see it on the
picture.
I clean.
If you stare at that picture,
you can actually see the total output must have gone up.
Who's good at looking at a picture?
Let me get the mic in here,
right?
The pictures of there.
Whoops.
Ah,
okay.
Okay.
Let me try this person.
So your name is Andy.
Andy,
if,
go ahead.
Uh,
judging by the slope of the line,
you know that as it moves,
the amount that Q one change will be greater than it not the Qq goes down.
Good.
So it's what Andy said up.
Put it in here,
everyone.
What ad is saying is look at the slope of the line along which we slid,
right when we went from [inaudible] to the Stackelberg equilibrium,
we started here and we slid in this direction down this line,
right?
Q.
I went up and Qsu went down.
And what Andy is pointing out is we can see from the slope of this line that Q
one goes up more than one unit for every unit of reduction of,
of,
uh,
of Q two.
Let me say it again.
For every unit of increase of Q1,
there's less than that.
Less than a report.
Sorry,
say it again.
For every unit of increase of Q1,
there's less than the unit of decrease of Qsu.
Right?
Another way of saying it is the slope of this line is less than one.
I want to see that.
Alright,
so we know by the slope of the line,
we know that Q one had to go up more than Q two went down,
which means total output went up,
which means that prices went what I'm into price is this total output went up.
That shouldn't be hard for everyone.
Second one 15 here,
right?
So in total output went up,
prices went down.
Good.
Right?
The cove slipping down,
it's not as important as backward induction,
but it's still quite important.
All right,
so prices went down.
So therefore we now already just say what happened to from two's.
Profits from two is producing less than before from two's costs to the same,
and prices have gone down.
So what's happened to from two's profits?
They've got it.
They must have gone down as well.
So from tos,
profit has gone down and we know that consumer surplus,
some sweat,
ces,
consumer surplus has gone up.
Right?
Consume it for those people.
Remember that one 15 prices have gone down,
quantity has gone up.
So consumer surplus,
yeah,
has gone up.
All right,
so we've analyzed everything qualitatively I can think of in this game without
reference to any math at all.
Is that right?
We,
we haven't done any math back and we generate a slope of a line.
I guess that's Matt.
I guess that's math then the junior high or something,
but we haven't really done any math there,
right?
Is that fair?
Is that fat?
All right,
and we already have a pretty good intuition for it's going to go on in this
market.
We think Q one is going to go up.
We think youtube is going to go down.
We think that from one's profit is going up.
We think from to profits are going down.
We think total quantity is going up.
All right,
now let's see if we're rights.
Let's go back and do the math.
All right.
So I want to spend a bit of time grinding this out.
So I don't claim that during the math is fun,
but I want to prove that we can do it because otherwise everyone's going to
either thing,
this was all kind of just blah,
Blah Blah and or people are going to be scared to do the math when it arrives on
a homework assignment.
All right,
so for now we're going to more or less,
but it's a few minutes.
We're going to forget where economists and we're going to turn into nerds.
That isn't a huge transition,
but what we'll do it anyway.
All right,
I've got the demand curve up there,
but let me,
all right,
so the demand curve is still there.
It's peak was a minus B Q one Q two and I've got profits written up there.
Uh,
but let's put them somewhere more convenient anyway.
So p equals a minus B.
He won plus Q two and profit
is equal to p per private firm from I is equal to Pqi minus Cqi.
Alright?
And what we were told to do and backward induction is what first of all,
solve things out for from to taking from one has given and then go back and
solve for from one.
So exactly the discussion we've just had informally.
We're not going to do,
we're going to do more formally.
Alright,
so backward induction tells us
solve for fum to first
taking Q one has given.
And what does that problem is the sort of boring math problem.
It says maximize by choosing Q2 the profits of from one to that's going to be a
minus B,
he won minus B Q two that's the price times the quantity Q2 minus c say,
all right,
so this,
this bit here
I spent here is the price,
these two terms together,
our revenues on these spits Turner's costs.
All right?
Now I could do that.
I could grow in that bit out,
but we ready ground that bit out three or three or four weeks ago,
right?
So I'm not going to grind it out again.
We know how to do that.
But by the way,
this is reminding us.
That is what we did.
We differentiated with respect to Q two we set the thing,
we found the derivative equal to zero.
That was off first all the condition and then we solve for Q two.
That right?
Is that right?
So when we did that,
when we did that,
we went through the first door to condition
and then we solved this.
We know what we actually got,
right?
So what we actually got was that Q two star,
if you like Q two as it's called,
this is equal to a mine,
the c over to B minus Q1 over to.
And in fact I've already given to help that it's,
it's on that top top board.
It's the best response for pharmacy.
So again,
I could do this again,
but we,
since we did it a few weeks ago,
I didn't want to Redo it.
All right.
Now the more interesting pause,
no thrilling,
but a little bit more interesting.
All right,
now let's solve full fun one.
so what is film one doing from one is also trying to maximize profits.
Farm one is take his choosing Q one and from one at least initially it looks
like the same problem.
It's a minus B Q one minus B Kutu Times Q one minus c Q one.
All right,
this is the same line we had before,
but now,
whereas from two was taking,
Q one has given from one knows that Q is given by this formula here.
All right,
so what we're gonna do is we're going to plug this cue to enter there.
All right?
Again,
for those of you in one 15 this isn't the only way to do it.
Sort of one 50 this isn't the only way we could do it.
We could also set up a little garage in equation,
but for those people who don't know what that is,
don't worry.
We're going to plug in today.
All right,
so we're going to plug this in and when we plug it in,
we get a right old mess,
but that's do it anyway,
so we're going to get Max Q one a minus B.
He one minus B pay brackets,
a minus c over to be minus Q one over too.
Why don't I put this,
see inside the bracket as well when I'm here.
Okay,
so minus c,
close bracket Q one.
All right,
so let's just while I'm at it one night,
put the sea inside the bracket.
Everyone okay with that?
I'm doing Algebra on the board,
which is not fun,
but it's useful to do occasionally.
All right,
so eventually what are we going to do?
Eventually we're going to differentiate this thing said that you called it a
zero in the car first or to condition and so on.
Just as we normally would.
Eventually we're going to use basically a one 12 level calculus to solve this
thing.
All right,
everyone,
them,
everyone remember how to,
how to map,
how to solve a maximization problem.
Yeah,
but before we do that,
let's tidy up the Algebra bet.
All right,
so this thing is,
is just tied it up.
So this is equal to Max Specter Q one.
A notice I've got,
I've got an um,
an a minus c here and a minus c here.
And once I take this,
be inside the brackets,
I've got a minus a minus three over to here.
Okay.
All right.
I got an a minus c minus and a minus t over two.
So that's going to give me an a minus c over too.
And I'm really gonna pray that the TA's are watching me Catholic going to catch
my errors here.
Okay.
If I think I'm okay so far,
but please catch me.
All right,
what else have I got?
I've got a minus B key one here and from in this bracket I've got a minus minus,
that's a plus B Q one over too much.
I have a minus B,
I have a minus Bq one.
Plasa Bq won over too.
So that's a minus B [inaudible] over two.
So far so good.
And that whole thing is multiplied by Q one.
Okay.
So far let's multiply out the bracket cause I otherwise I'll make a mistake.
So this is the same as saying a minus c over two times Q one minus B Q one
squared over two.
So far so good.
All right.
Now we're at the level where even my very rusty,
uh,
memory of calc test will get us through.
Okay?
So let's try and do it.
It's all going to do is we're going to differentiate this thing with respect to
Q one.
All right?
It's differentiate with Hector Q one.
Okay,
so a differentiating respect to Q1.
Let's do it up here.
Differentiate with respects to Q1.
We get a minus c
over to from this term.
All right,
and from the minus Bq squared over two we're going to get the two are going to
cancel all the pleasant late,
so we're going to get be Q1 from that term.
Yeah.
All right,
everyone with me so far?
I'm going through this and so slow steps.
I really,
I agree it's not exciting but I want to try it out.
Make a mistake.
All right,
so let's turn this into a first door to condition.
What must be true about this derivative at that?
At the maximum,
what must be true,
but this derivative
equal to zero.
Good,
so you got a zero.
All right,
we should just check the second order condition.
All right.
How do I check the second order conditioning?
I differentiate again and check it's negative,
but I differentiate.
Again,
I'm just going to get minus B minus B is certainly negative,
right?
So second order conditions.
Okay.
Does that solve it out?
Solving this for Q one I get Q1 is equal to a minus c over to Ben.
All right.
Tell me what to leading and sheer boredom.
It has to be done occasionally,
right?
Q one is a minus c over to be all right,
and we're not done yet.
No one want to go back and saw that algebraically for Qsu.
I know Q one is now can you want as a minus t over to be?
How do I find Q2 somebody shout it out.
How do I find,
how do I find two to now I've got to plug it in,
right?
I got to pee.
I'm going to go back and plug this Q one
back into this expression here.
It's my plug it back in and I'll get Q two is equal to a minus c over to B minus
a half of a minus c over to B for a total of a minus.
Uh,
see,
uh,
over
four B.
Is that right?
That's what happened.
My notes.
This looks good.
All right,
so I'm now done.
I'm not found that equilibrium.
I found that in this leader followship gave this Stackelberg version of quantity
competition.
Q one is given by a minus C of a to B
and Q two is given by a minus C of a for B.
Let's see how it matches up with the intuition we developed before without using
any boring math.
All right,
so first of all,
what comparing Q one and Q two with what they used to produce and what they used
to produce is on the top board?
Well they used to produce,
I can use this to guide the camera as well.
Well they used to produce is a minus c over three B,
is that right?
So our claim was that we think the new Q one is bigger than the old corner
quantity.
So now,
now from one is producing a minus c over tubey.
Previously it was bruising a minus c over three B.
It's not is indeed bigger.
That's good news.
All right,
so this is indeed
bigger than coupon.
No.
And our claim was that from two or produce less than the old corn.
Oh quantity.
So from a,
from to use to produce a minus c over three B and now it's producing a minus t
over four B.
And that is indeed less than the old corner.
Quasi.
All right,
so far so good.
What about total output?
How do I solve for total output?
Add the two outputs together.
That's not too hard.
All right,
so Q one
plus Q two
is equal to am I in a c over to B plus a minus t over four B,
which is in fact a three AC over three ac over four B.
Is that right?
So it's going to be a three a minus c over four beats.
So I just actually for the first time today I skipped a stack,
but is that okay?
A half plus a quarter of three quarters.
Okay.
All right,
so,
so total outputs is three AC over four B.
What was total output before
weight used to be the core?
No total outputs.
It's put it here somewhere.
This is bigger than to a minus c over three B.
Which is equal to the corner quantity.
He wants the plus QCC.
All right,
so everything we predicted just by looking at the picture and thinking about the
economics works out in the math.
That's a good thing.
We should feel a little bit relieved.
I'm getting a little bit relieved.
All right.
Everything we thought about it and she really just using the economics,
the logic of the situation when we grind out the Algebra we get the right
answers.
We get confirming answers.
Alright.
Ever a case that there isn't a particularly fun exercise per se,
but I want to do it just to show that you can use backward induction to solve
that problems.
Exactly right.
Backward induction and a little bit of what you learned in the,
in the high school and or freshman calculus can get you the answer.
All right.
All right,
so now I want to leave aside the math and go back to the economics again.
so we started off with a question.
Who would you rather be from one or from to,
and we know the answer now.
Who would you rather be from?
One off them too from one right?
Cause for one's profits went up and from two's profits went down.
Let's just talk about this a little bit about what's going on here.
So from one in previously one and two are just sending quantities and Martinez
sleep,
right?
We know now there's an advantage in going first.
So I suppose we changed the game from the simultaneous move game to a game in
which foam one and form two can make announcements.
All right?
They can announce how much they going to produce.
So from one comes in one day and says,
I'm going to produce this much and found two comes in and can see foam ones
announcements,
right?
So change it.
I've changed into a sequential game from one is announced how much it's going to
produce from two is going to go afterwards.
Is that really a sequential game?
Is that going to make a difference?
Why is that?
I claim that's not really enough.
Let me say it again.
We start,
we start from the simultaneous move game.
If we just change it by simply allowing from one to announce what they're going
to produce,
don't actually produce it,
but just announced what they're going to produce.
You might think that's a sequential move game and you might think that from one
now has an advantage.
But I'm claiming that's not enough already.
The gift from one advantage.
Why?
Why is that not enough?
Let's try and get some ideas.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
we come around this side,
so
yes.
So Patrick,
why is,
why is that not enough?
There's no credible commitment that you're going to produce it that level.
Good.
So imagine these two firms are,
uh,
let's say that they're a newspaper producing firms and one is owned by a nbcs
parent company and one is owned by Rupert Murdoch.
Right?
And then move,
they're moving into this new market and the market is a town that that's a but
both.
I'm going to eat it again.
I'm going to issue newspapers and this market and this market that currently
doesn't have any newspapers and murder ultimately says,
I'm going to produce lots of newspapers.
Right?
There's no reason for NBC to believe that.
All right?
So moving first here,
it isn't enough to just say you're going to move first.
It isn't enough even to make a decision that's reversible,
right?
Even if even if you want move.
But that was,
that decision could be undone.
That isn't enough.
What we need,
and Patrick had gave us the key word.
What we need is commitment.
The word that came up last week.
All right,
so for this,
for this,
for moving first to help you here,
there really has to be commitment.
Let's just get some of this down.
The really needs to be commitment for this to work.
So going back to the example of Murdoch and his competitor,
uh,
Modo actually has to build the plant that actually has to be a factory that he's
built in.
I'm not factory can't just be sold for scrap,
right?
So what craves the commitment and the case when you've built the plant is what,
because having built it,
it's a sunk cost.
It's there,
right?
So sunk costs can help here.
Okay,
sunk costs
can help,
we can help make you,
you committed.
Once that money is gone,
you can't get it back.
So you're really committed to that,
to that,
to that scale.
Does everyone know what I mean by Seung costs by the way?
Yup.
Okay.
So here's a case where a strategic move entering first and sinking some
investments can help you in the market place.
All right,
let's also look at this another way.
Let's again go back to the simultaneous move game that we had before where a
Murdoch and his competitor,
the NBC Parent Compact Corporation,
Ah,
ah,
um,
in fact going to move simultaneously.
So both of them are in the business of discussing how big a newspaper plant to
put in this new town,
which hasn't got a newspaper yet.
All right.
Somewhere in Alabama or something.
I don't know.
All right.
I suppose suppose that,
uh,
that there are two boardrooms,
both of which are avidly just trying to discuss how big a newspaper plant to
bells.
All right.
So suppose that one of the board rooms,
one of the board rooms are these four people on this,
this road.
This is,
this is the,
uh,
NBC parent company boardroom it and they're trying to decide how big a plant to
bells.
All right.
And uh,
over on the other side of the room is our,
uh,
our Murdoch group,
which is in fact,
uh,
let's take the,
the road parallel.
So these guys over there or our mode on our news international group.
All right,
there's this simultaneous move back games.
So basically we're in corner.
All right now I suppose that Murdoch just to pick a name out of the hat and
meant what might not be the most moral gentleman in the world.
Who knows and suppose that he in fact has hired one of the people in the NBC a
board room.
In fact,
this guy,
what's his name?
Ryan.
He's hired Ryan to be a spy.
So Murdoch has a spy in the,
in the NBC boardroom.
So mono has got an advantage here information wise.
Why?
Because the NBC boardroom doesn't know what's going on in the Murdoch board.
A board room,
but the murder board,
a board room,
it is going to know what's going on in the MBC boardroom.
But to make them a problem more interesting.
Suppose that somebody tells NBC parent company then in fact there is a spy in
their boardroom.
Right?
So these guys know that they have a spy.
They don't know it.
It if they knew it was they beat him up or farm or something.
Well maybe not.
All right,
but,
but they know that someone's,
there aren't men.
Maybe they even suspect it's Ryan.
So what should NBC do here?
I wash it.
What decisions did NBC mate,
one thing they could do is they could earn,
they don't know it's Ryan,
but Ryan has a sort of Murdoch face and they might just fire him on that.
He might be a spy,
right?
Oh,
what should they do here?
Can you take us,
if you're on the mood,
you're in the embassy boardroom,
you know that Murdoch has some spying the camp.
What should you do?
You can come up with it
fake plan and see if it goes back to Murdoch.
All right,
so,
so your,
your name is Chris.
So Chris is suggesting come up with a fake plan to feed it back to Moodle.
So Chris has been reading spy novels,
right?
Right.
So this was a John Le Carre novel.
That's certainly what you do.
You create a whole bunch of fake information to feed back to the Russians right
through this by who in fact you've discovered all right.
And,
and that,
that isn't a bad idea.
That might,
that might be a good thing to do.
It's pretty hard to do,
right?
Because ultimately this,
this actual decisions have to be made in the boardroom.
Contracts have to be assigned and so on.
But I think Chris,
to the right idea here so quick,
Chris's idea is create a fake plan to feed back to Modok to give mode up some
misinformation.
But there's another thing you could do.
I mean,
and it gets my husband,
it's contributed yet.
Anyone and anyone else.
Yeah.
What's your name?
What's going on?
So it was mine.
What would you do these guys get the first move now effectively because they can
just decide.
They know,
say what you just said,
but shout out to everyone going to hear.
Um,
NBC now gets the first move because they can decide and they know the other
people are going to respond to it.
All right,
good.
Good.
So,
so I was man,
what asthma is suggesting is maybe you don't feed Murdoch a fake plan.
You fake you,
you feed mode out in the true plan.
Right?
Offensively what's going to happen now is if NBC decided to build a large plant,
this information will be fed back to Murdoch and Murdoch is now in the position
of being the second mover,
right?
What,
when,
when murder moves,
he or she knows what NBC is doing,
right?
And NBC knows that Murdoch is going to choose the best response to that.
So it has,
if NBC has been moved,
has been put in the position of I'm one and Murdoch has been put into the
position of I'm too even with the correct plan.
So the correct,
the correct thing to do here from NBC is not,
not necessarily to mislead Murdoch,
but just go ahead and build a big pumps,
have that information be fed to Murdoch and that Murdoch respond to it.
So notice here isn't it as a slightly paradoxical thing.
You might think that having a spy in the camp of the other team having a spy,
you might think having a spy would help you,
but here having a spy or having more information that you like,
having more information
can actually end up hurting you.
All right.
I want to see that.
Paradoxically,
Murdock ends up losing by the fact that he,
he,
he was able to predict what NBC we're going to.
Now there's a key to this.
Of course it was crucial to the arguments.
What was crucial to the argument.
It was crucial to the arguments that NBC knew that Murdoch had a spy.
Right?
The key here is,
Huh?
That the other side,
the other players,
the other players new
you had,
we're going to have more information,
right?
So what's the bigger idea here?
There are two bigger ideas.
Bigger idea.
Number one is games being simultaneous or sequential is not really about timing
per se.
It's about information.
It's about who knows what and who knows that.
Who's going to know what my,
in a situation where from one our boardroom over here knows that Murdoch is
going to have this information before MODOK moves.
That's actually a sequential game,
right?
The timing is how much I like a relevant,
how's the first observation.
And the second observation is already on the board.
What we've learned is sometimes more in strategic settings,
sometimes it's not always more information can hurt you.
Sometimes more information can hurt,
will be careful here because that's not always true.
But sometimes it's true and the way that,
the reason that's true is the reason is
it can lead other players.
Yeah.
So take actions in this case to create a large plant
that hurts you.
Have you put Monday's lecture together with today's lecture,
we've seen something in uh,
to two very simple things arose on Monday's lecture.
Having fewer options,
burning your boats ended up helping you or having lower payoffs by putting
collateral down ended up helping you.
And that might seem like a paradox,
but it isn't really a paradox because what happened was provided the other side
knows you have fewer options.
I know you've brought your boats or they know your software,
a few defaults on the loan,
they know you've posted collateral.
It will lead them to take behavior that helps you.
In the case of the loan,
it led to the lender giving you a bigger loan.
In the case of the sacks,
know me,
you at least hope it leads to the Saxon army running away,
right?
Today we see that more information can hurt you.
And once again,
it isn't really a paradox.
It's the same kind of argument.
The fact that the other side,
no,
you're going to have this extra information leads them to take actions that end
up hurting you.
Alright?
So in games,
unlike him in a standard single person decision problems,
more information can hurt and more options can hurt.
All right,
and here's the reason.
now one other thing to say about this.
The game we just looked at the Stackelberg game we just looked at as an example
of something pretty famous.
It's an example of first mover advantage.
It's an example of a game with a first mover
advantage.
Alright?
Now,
how many of you have heard how many are in the room,
have heard the term first mover advantage before spheres that seriously,
how many of the rest of you,
how many of you have not heard the term first mover advantage before?
We don't want to see.
All right,
so I'm always wary of first mover advantage as a terminal.
If you ask the students in the business school,
how many of you have heard the term,
they've all heard it.
It's a very popular business school term.
It's a very popular term that you see in bad books.
So let me just warn you a little bit about this.
So if you go to the,
to the airport,
let's say to Hartford airport and the flight you want to get on his late,
which is usually the case and you hence you end up in the bookstore and you find
yourself on the economics and business shells,
you start looking at the a a strategy books and typically the kind of book you
find that the airports on business or strategy or economics is a pretty bad
book.
All right,
so it has some,
it has some embossed cover and it says strategy for dummies or uh,
my boring life by a famous CEO,
right?
And I worry about these books because you ended up buying these books.
You've got time on your hands and you read them and they give you absolutely
terrible advice.
All right?
So not always,
but almost always.
And the kinds of things they'll say is it's always a good idea to move first
because that way you'll have a first mover advantage.
Alright?
And this sounds right.
I'm always worried about things that sound rights because they may be sound
right,
Mimi in there,
right?
But the promise,
if they're wrong,
that tempting they,
there's,
there's a law you in,
right?
So it's good to move first cause that we have a first mover advantage sounds
right,
but it's nonsense,
right?
There are situations of which this is one,
there are situations where it's good to move first in quantity competition.
It's good to set your quantity to be committed and that will lead the other side
to produce things,
a smaller quantity,
which helps you so sure that all situations that are games in which you want to
move first,
but there are also games in which you'd rather move second.
Let me give you an example.
All right?
This is his own voice in this class before rock,
paper,
scissors.
All right?
If anybody is going to read those books and believe them,
you know,
so if anyone's going to read,
uh,
you know how,
how to discover your Inner Bill Gates and base their life on it and therefore I
think there's a first mover advantage.
I want to play rock,
paper,
scissors.
Was that person?
All right?
All right.
Everyone happy that you'd,
you'd rather go second and rock,
paper,
scissors.
Do I need to prove that or is that all of it?
Okay.
Okay,
good.
All right.
Let me just expand a little bit,
a bit more and more into a more real world setting.
There are plenty of settings in the real world where the advantage of moving
second,
isn't it?
Because as in rock,
paper,
scissors,
you've just got to crush the other guy.
It's simply that you learn from their mistakes.
All right,
so for example,
in the game of buying new equipment for the office or home,
it's great to move.
Second,
the other guy goes out and [inaudible] samples,
some new piece of equipment.
I wait to see if it's,
see if it works and then buy it.
If it does,
all right,
or if I'm sitting up from in a new expanding market,
let's say a new part of the former Soviet Union,
I'm quite happy to let some other firms go in there first and then watch what
they did and try and learn from their mistakes.
If I'm seeing a new curriculum for a university,
I'm quite happy to let other universities do can Cornell and so on move first
and then I can go in and Yay,
I'll see what they did and for sure that we've made mistakes and I learned from
that.
All right.
There's plenty of obvious situations where moving second helps you for the
obvious reason,
that information is often very useful,
right?
We all,
you'd hear information can hurt you,
but there's plenty of other perfectly natural situations we're in a information
is to your advantage.
All right,
so they're all games is first mover advantages,
but there are also games with second mover advantages.
And let me give you one example of a game that neither has a first mover
advantage or a second mover advantage just to convince you that can happen as
well.
So when you were a child,
you probably occasionally a hat to divide a cake and or candy bar with your
siblings,
anyone,
anyone to be in this situation there was some candy bar or a cake and you had to
divide.
This thing was in you and your brother and our sister,
is that right?
And there's a way in which there's a typical way in which we divide things among
siblings in that setting.
There's a game we played to divide it.
What's the game we play?
Anyone?
Yeah,
all cotton you choose or vice versa.
Right?
So all cotton you choose Nike that has a first mover advantage or a second mover
advantage.
I assuming you can cut accurate late at night that has a first mover advantage
or a second movie volunteers,
which is precisely why it's a good way to divide the candy bar.
All right?
Not a rub this point home and because we've had a very dry and extra up are now
let's play a game.
All right,
so everyone would wake up.
Now math is over.
I want to play a game and the game I want to play for the rest of today is
called Nim
and it's not going to surprise you that one of the things we're going to learn
in this game is that sometimes games have a first mover advantage and sometimes
games have a second mover advantage.
So I'm giving away the punchline.
How many of you have played in them before?
Okay,
if you played it before,
you can't play now,
right?
So it didn't,
don't shout out.
All right,
so this is the game.
There are two players and there are two piles of stones.
We'll make the piles of stones into,
into just chalk lines on the board.
The players are going to move sequentially in each turn.
The player who's turn it is to move,
picks one of the two piles and removes some of the stones,
which will just be lines on the board.
So they did,
they decide how many of those lines to delete each time it's your turn you out,
you get to move again.
You can choose the other pile.
This time you move sequentially.
And the only,
the rule that matters is the person who gets the last stone wins.
All right?
So for example,
here's a case where there's one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven stones on this pile and one,
two,
three,
four stones on this pile.
All right,
so I'm going to get some volunteers to come on the stage and do this,
but I was told I should choose a volunteer.
So is uh,
is leashing Chang here,
at least in Shanghai.
It's Allegion.
Shannon's going to volunteer for this.
I'm,
I'm volunteering.
Leashing Chang cause it's his birthday.
All right,
so,
so then you get a round of applause.
Felician Chang,
you come on and say
[inaudible]
who wants to play against leashing Chang?
That's it.
Maybe anyone else wanna play.
Who hasn't played a game yet.
How about the guy with a Yale hat on back there?
Uh,
the white yellow hat.
I'm staring right at the guy.
He's not,
yeah,
you,
this is going to come up.
All right.
What's your,
what's your name?
Evan.
Evan and unleashing T.
Is it leashing?
Leashing and haven't come up on the stage.
There's a step up yet.
Come on.
All right.
All right,
so we'll let,
we'll let leashing go first and when I haven't go second then you played this
game before.
Okay.
How did you hear the games?
Who explained the rules again?
Well,
these people are sleeping.
All right.
And who was sleeping then?
The game is backward induction,
but,
okay,
so,
all right,
so the rules of the game of this,
they're going to take turns in each turn Vegan to pick one of these two piles.
This is pile a and this is pile B and they're going to tell me how many of these
chalk lines to delete.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Thank you.
They're going to tell me how many of these chalk lines to delete.
Thanks.
All right.
And I'm going to leave this lines.
We're going to go on playing until,
until somebody gets the last line.
The person who gets the last line wins.
Okay.
I guess the last one,
when you can take,
you can get the last line tended to go.
It doesn't have to.
It doesn't have to be the only one on the board when you get the last time.
But the person who gets the last line wins.
All right,
so have to pick a pile each go and tell me how many lines to remove.
So Lisa,
why don't you go first?
You can choose pylay or pile B and tell me how many lines to remove.
Any advice from the audience?
No advice is you want to on your own hand.
Okay.
Can you remove three from pile a three from pile a.
Okay,
so three from pile a uh,
Evan,
your time.
Okay.
What are you standing there with the board so we can get you in there.
Have A,
and your move to from pilot to firm to firm pile a.
Okay,
so pile is the pocket up while on here.
Two from pile B two from pile of B.
Okay.
Spence,
this building here,
one from pile B,
one from pile B.
Right.
Should get fostered the stage.
Go on to from pile a weight loss.
Don't wins.
Last stoneware
lost.
Don't wind Catholic.
It's his birthday.
Come on.
Last stone wins the person who gets the last stone winds personally.
So one from a,
all right.
One from a
kind of stay.
And so I from B,
one from beat the Lisa is the winner here.
All.
Alright.
Hi.
Very good.
Let's get two more volunteers.
All so everyone understand the game now.
Thank you very much then hun.
All right,
two more volunteers.
Yeah.
Have you played before?
Come.
Come on.
I want to get some female volunteers.
It can't be a male only class.
There we go.
Thank you.
This may not be as important in economics and doing the Stackelberg model,
but it's probably a little more fun.
All right,
and your names are John,
Christine,
John and Christine.
Okay.
All right,
so,
okay,
so let's make it a bit more complicated this time.
So one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11,
12,
13 and one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
So I'll pick two prime numbers if that's important and see what is,
uh,
why don't we say ladies first?
I think we've probably today.
So Christina,
your choice.
Uh,
this one started off at 13,
I believe.
And this one started off at seven to me,
I counted correctly.
We get out of the way.
Six from piling six,
six for about here.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Is that right?
One,
two,
three.
Okay.
Three from pile bay three from pile,
B,
three from piling.
Three from pile,
a,
one from pile day one from pile,
be right.
Here's one from Thailand.
All right.
It's right.
We're onto this right.
One from pile B,
one from pilot.
Alright,
one from pal bit.
All right.
One from Pilate.
Alright,
one from pile.
A.
Ah,
okay.
It'll switch one from pile B.
All right,
so I'm going to see it as the way now.
Okay.
Okay,
so round of applause for these two.
All right.
So I think everyone's figured out now how to play this game.
Is that right?
Does everyone figured it out?
All right,
let me,
uh,
take one of these mics and go down and make sure that I'm asking people to
figure this out.
All right,
so,
so what is the,
what is the role of how to play this game?
What's the rule of how to play this game?
People haven't figured out with the pie again,
Susan,
let's try over here.
Someone that someone has a,
an onset.
How should you play this game?
Yeah,
it depends on whether the piles have the same number in them.
All right?
If they have the same number you want to be second player and if they have
different numbers,
you want to be first player.
All right?
And what's your go to?
What should you do you want to,
this is,
do they have different numbers?
If they have different numbers,
you want to make them equal.
You want to make them equal.
All right.
So the,
the trick to playing this game is,
thank you.
Very good.
The tricks we're playing this game is you.
If the piles are on,
even then you want to make them even want to make them equal.
I want to see that.
So you start off with the piles being on equal as we did both times.
For example,
three and two.
Then you want to be player one.
There's a first mover advantage and the correct tactic is to equalize the piles.
All right?
And what you'll notice now is the player to can't do anything.
If they take two from here,
you'll win by taking both of those two.
I think one from here you'll equalize the piles again and if they take then one
from here you've won.
All right?
So the way to play this game is to equalize the piles.
What does that mean?
It means if you're,
if the initial position has the army cool piles on even piles,
then you would rather be player one.
It has a first mover advantage,
but if the initial position has an even number of uh,
has even numbers in the piles,
then you'd rather be playing it too.
Is that right?
Right.
Because if it's,
if,
if you start off with an even number
in each pile,
the person moving first it's going to make them honor you quilt
and thereafter the next person's in a winning position.
So I want to do is two things from this game.
First notice in this game that from any initial position we can very quickly
tell who is going to win and who's going to lose assuming they play.
Well
three things nightmarishly third,
second,
sorry.
Second,
we didn't actually use backward induction here but it's pretty obvious.
You do want to use backward induction here.
You want to figure out what the end game going to look like.
That right?
It's very easy to see you this game if you look at the end game.
Alright?
And the third lesson is what we just said in this game.
Sometimes there's a first mover advantage,
sometimes there's a second mover advantage of the first.
That's not,
you'd ever,
ever have any cycles,
right?
So sometimes there's a first mover advantage in this game.
Sometimes there's a second mover advantage in this game.
All right.
I'm just illustrating the point we made earlier.
That is that it is not always the case that you want to move first.
Sometimes you want to move second hour.
Today I thought the piles with on equal piles.
So there was a first mover advantage,
but that was just to give an advantage to the guy whose birthday it was.
All right.
I could have set things up with equal equal lines in each pile and made the
other guy,
the guy who I,
uh,
the other guy,
you go first.